Hey, I've got something really interesting
for you here.
Uh, Jeanine Pirro, who is a former judge,
I mean shocked. She actually was a judge at
one point, and it's an incredible indictment
on the American justice system. She's now
a Fox News host. She went on Cspan and it
did not go well at all. She has been one of
the persistent, outrageous, the opposite of
a never Trumper and always Trumper unhinged
defender of Donald Trump on Fox news just
persistently all the time. Any crazy notion
from Donald Trump, she will defend. She went
on a c-span program called Washington Journal.
People call in to that show and she was straight
up confronted by a color. This is a caller
from Texas who reamed her out so severely
in such a way that she was visibly unclear,
unsure what to do. She either could not respond
or chose not to respond. She looks visibly
stunned by this dressing down that a caller
gave her. Take a look at this.
All right. Our president and our beautiful
first lady, um, they went down to El Paso,
Texas, and they posed with a baby that the
president's rhetoric, Fox News, rhetoric,
your rhetoric had helped to orphan. And I
think this, this thing about Trump is making
America great again. Trump has made America
hate again and it's this hatred of racist.
I hear it all the time when I see talk to
Republicans and they say, Oh, I went down
to Texas and there are all these Mexicans
down there and they're all speaking Spanish.
Well, I got news for you. Those weren't Mexicans.
Those were the Americans. That guy that went
down to El Paso to shoot a bunch of Mexicans.
He shot a bunch of Americans and I'm really
tired of this anti-immigrant anti people with
brown skin rhetoric that's coming out of out
of Fox News coming out of people like you
and coming out of our president. It's demeaning,
it's beneath the office. It's beneath. You
used to be a judge, you know better. It's
time that that stopped and
thank you Carol. We'll get a response.
Look, I, you know what? I refuse to accept
your recitation of the facts. You are dead
Wong. The problem in this country, but the
color of anyone and don't you dare accuse
me of any kind of issue related to color.
I am 30 years of prosecuting without fear
or favor and making sure that hate crimes
were vigorously prosecuted. I fought for,
I fought for a hate crimes law. It's
genuinely shocking that she didn't interrupt
and the look on her face of growing confusion
and this almost inability to jump in is really
priceless. If you just, if you're just listening,
you should definitely watch the clip. Beautiful
to see. Now, not everything that guy said
was a hundred percent true, but he did pretty
accurately get into this idea of stochastic
terrorism that I've been talking about for
a long time and the impact of what Jeanine
Pirro and other Fox Trump flunkies do and
the effect that it has on the real world.
She has made commentaries on Fox News that
have suggested that Democrats entice undocumented
Hispanic immigrants to come to the United
States so that they can vote for Democrats.
This is something that had a prominent role
in the El Paso shooters manifesto. The idea
of I need to go take out Hispanic people because
Democrats are in bed with them and bringing
them to the u s to try to turn elections in
their favor.
I don't know what's crazier that she was a
judge, which is nuts. I mean, it is, it is
insane that this is someone who was actually
a judge, uh, or that she continues to be a
Fox News host this time, despite participating
in this blind, a Radek reflexive loyalty to
the president and even kind of becoming an
aggravating factor in many of the problems
that the president is creating himself. There
are actually lots of really crazy right-wing
judges. We think of judges as these sort of
a, uh, beyond partisanship arbiters of the
law in some way. Uh, and you have to look
only at the fact that Jeanine Pirro was a
judge, that crazy Texas Congressman Louie
Gohmert was a judge, if I recall correctly.
And this gets to the bigger problem of judges.
There are so many right-wingers who talk about
they want textual conservative justices. What
they are actually talking about our complete
and total partisan hacks.
Who Do the opposite of simply be conservative.
If conservative means a merely applying the
letter of the law to the circumstances they
do that if it helps Republicans and big corporations
or whoever they want to help. And if it doesn't,
they take a completely different, not conservative
but simply activists. Right wing perspective
as judges for context. Here's another color
during Janine Pyrrho's who is a complete and
total right-wing lunatic saying I'm not racist
but we white people legally obtained our guns.
Drawing a contrast I guess to non white people
and then saying that Jeanine Pirro is a genius
and that Donald Trump would be really well,
uh, uh, would be really smart to listen to
her and also slam cspan itself during the
opening. This is just another color during
Janine pyros appearance.
Hi Judge. Um, I know you thought you'd get
a fair shot here on Washington general fleets
then, but as you see, you get six to seven
Democrat collars to one Republican. That's
that they're just as bad as CNN with the fake
news about Donald Trump bay attacking just
as much as anybody. So dre k y you can sister.
Cause you probably won't be invited back.
Well, let me, let me tell you, that's not
true. Our taking calls from Democrats, Republicans,
and independents, uh, we welcome hear her
for the hour and judge denning, you're welcome
back anytime. We'd love to have you. But caller,
go ahead.
Thank you so much. Um, judging being a prosecutor.
Um, I feel that the Democrats are attacking
only white people's guns and I'm not being
racist, but what I'm saying is way legally
obtain our guns. We go to buy our firearms.
Did we fill out background checks? And the
thing that upsets me the most, and I do hope
that Donald Trump listens to you. Cause I
know you are a very smart woman and we need
people like you talking to Donald Trump. But
I fear that he doesn't see what's going on.
You can find the rest of that call online
where they go into the normal black on black
crime talking points in all of the stuff you
would expect. Really scary what's going on,
why Janine Pirro is even on C-span is beyond
me. That seems to be the real problem selling
her hack book. Uh, but at least one call or
really backing her off and she was visibly
an unclear, unsure about how to respond. Let
me know if you saw this entire appearance.
It was wacky and make sure you're following
me.
Can you the talking shit on Instagram actually
the path can show to communicate your splits
rate. You can do doc right after the David
Pakman show